[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back off the record
where we talk about whatever we won and
David drops his phone that's right
airplane love [ __ ] thank you so much
for having me thank you thank you you
sound like a ball of energy I have so
much energy right now I'm already like
let's go let's hear it well I drove here
from Studio City
oh the long drive girl thank you for
coming to moderate yeah yeah it's where
I live so I haven't been here in like a
minute I like this area though the
people are really awesome you do out
here yeah you come here to eat Chinese
food is that why cuz most people come
out to Monterey Park to do that I dated
a guy that lived out here didn't work
out no he wasn't Chinese they had a low
Chinese friends I know that was a
demographic I know her look but yeah
I've been dating a lot I got yeah we're
just looking at a car outside your last
guest at a car here and I was like okay
I dated this guy he was really into cars
I could give a [ __ ] less about cars so I
know the boys were into it but I was
just like can we just take this place I
always have to pretend like I'm super
into it so I look like one of the boys
love you actually you and I bonded over
that that's what he loves David you
can't say that nobody loves David face
his face is amazing what's wrong with us
exactly okay you're either high or
you're really nice I've been learning
that from Game of Thrones your country
do you watch Game of Thrones wow I love
Game of Thrones okay can anyone do other
accents other than that one I just know
they say me Lord [ __ ] I just came in
hard all [ __ ] up I mean I was into it
thank you nah no wait let's go I feel
like you I don't really know you know
it's gross good no I felt like from the
north or something I don't know it's
okay I mean to my ears I mean I wish
Scottish it's real I don't know
there's a wildling girl she sucks gas
welding you know nothing Jon Snow yeah
Jon Snow yeah but like how weird was
that that like the last episode I'm like
based hasn't watched it okay cool yeah
yeah basically
okay so honestly I didn't watch the
first one cuz everyone was dogging it I
was like whatever I loved the first one
really yeah no yeah this last yeah yeah
the first episodes the second one
basically Khaleesi and Jon Snow figure
out but they're like related and then
John's like I [ __ ] you you're my
sister
yep sort of thing those like isn't that
more something to do in the South
northern thing but whatever let's do it
and the dragon really is not that scary
the ice one or the one that's like sad
no he tore down the whole wall by
himself with that scary dude okay but it
made me laugh the guy that was on it I'm
like literally okay you look like
someone from Halloween on Santa Monica
Boulevard you know what anybody was like
it wasn't it didn't really like scare me
me because that law hasn't been taken
down in 10,000 years yeah
supposed to be invincible you sound
really concerned about that actually I
believe all my baby but then like did we
want her to lose her virginity like oh
yeah like I don't want to see your tits
like I was like no you die sorry
I wouldn't be knit you need to purchase
late to the party yeah she's not a
virgin anymore yeah she's the only thing
that thing is is she old enough to be
doing this right
yes exactly who's old enough or is REO
old enough
well maybe is maybe seems like a
pedophile
yeah and she's like how many guys have
you a bitter girl yeah then you'd like a
lot I know you've had a lot of lovers
there let's [ __ ] like really know like
it the one that's an interesting [ __ ] is
what's the granite heart
but the that guy Oh tormak Podrick with
the crazy dick wait crazy dick is that
he knows how to use it oh I bet you men
it was a crazy big dig no because they
made that joke they're like so the size
is like no it's average just what he
doesn't let him pay I know wait a minute
I don't know this character cuz I'm like
hi hot drink what was that but he used
to be the squire of two young I had the
brothel you know no RIANZ band Squire
now he's best Petyr Baelish don't
computer Petyr Baelish with Podrick yeah
okay away I need a photo of this but
everyone's on airplane mode how do I not
know this character well the last
episode right he's the one singing no
drinking they're all drinking and
Tyrians like you know that anyone know a
song and he's he busts out and starts
singing see I was so annoyed with the
episode because she like lost her
virginity that I like was on my phone at
that point like [ __ ] you people I'm not
watching you okay wait do you guys watch
like after though there's a shot all the
inside yeah can we just say like they
said in like every other way that that's
all what's the tall girl's name again
that one oh wait okay wait that's not
very talking about whatever I don't
[ __ ] know their names
it's like spoilers don't ruin the show
for me because he'll forget it yeah even
if I don't forget it it's watching it
and yeah when people say this yeah it's
not about that too it's not like it's a
murder mystery you know yeah yeah yeah
you want to see oh then this next
episode Brienne totally wanted his dick
whoever that guy is I don't know his
Jaime Lannister that blew my mind
because I didn't I didn't know Bree I
love each other I didn't know that she
loved him what she wanted a dick I
didn't know that how did you not know
that I didn't sprinkle throughout the
whole thing
I mean it else's job that's true John
doesn't really know until until I
watched that part I was like oh wow she
she likes him like that we were like duh
I mean yeah I have used to ever seen her
interview out of character like herself
she seems like a really nice person
yeah she definitely seems like she likes
dick in real life yeah for sure she
talking about Game of Thrones I really
want to get to know ya what do you know
uh um well like what part of my life is
in such a mess she's from Studio City
from Studio yeah I'm originally from
Georgia I've been in LA for 12 years
moved out when I was 16 with my mom and
two sisters and was the American Academy
of Dramatic Arts well you see your whole
family came here for the Arts oh yeah my
sister was a playmate and now she does
porn and then my la stereotype like come
out here for acting and then go to poor
boys actually she actually came here
because she got her centerfold like she
worked at Hooters before that she
murders calendar all then became a
center pill she's building a resume yeah
exactly
exactly but she only works with women so
she doesn't think that she's important
yeah okay Spencer why you had the avians
accepting like a golden titty like I
don't get it
well yeah they're huge they're like
massive um but now my other sister who
lives with me I can't stand her she's
the casting director who won't put me in
anything high cuz she's a [ __ ] laughter
I guess it's Kyler
listen I'm doing this show today like I
have to go I have to catch a 6:00
o'clock flight tomorrow to go work good
job in Atlanta and I was like will you
please go to supports right across the
street all she has to do is walk those
like I'll give you $50 no I'm like you
really like please we did such a [ __ ]
she's probably carry also bullying from
her child childhood years yeah she she's
the old I mean yeah I was such a [ __ ] I
was it's probably all they got to that
oh sure oh yeah but she's also she
writes and like directs and produces and
she's got like webseries uses all my
[ __ ] equipment I look yeah you know
it's like one of those things and then
my mom is the celebrity baby nurse so
she works with I can't say their names
but like big people people that you
probably see on TV
and so she knows everything about Skype
of activities actually she got a
contract to be with someone that you
would like freak the [ __ ] brahh James
that's here yeah yeah LeBron James so
yeah so that's um that's my family and
then my dad is obviously not involved or
also none of us would move out here when
I was 16 that's like one of those like
sad happy laughs dude oh yeah I'm daddy
issues have any probably - you have
mommy issues and you're gonna love me
because I see mommy issues love me I
don't have mommy issues no my mom's
great but I have daddy issues okay
perfect yeah yeah how do you have them
huh let's talk about you you know it's
like let's have a therapy session you
know what they just like we're all we're
kind of I guess la locals except for
David over here yeah yeah so then I've
never really met well because you're
kind of considered I mean you've been
here since you're in your team I know
partner right but yeah but you you're
you're kind of like this demographic of
young like team like child actor
aspiring that comes here and you have a
supportive parent that pushes you
through that like stage mom style right
should I wish she would have been a
stage mom no I had a pair of my own damn
selves I was like okay I figure I want
to get a car an audition what's she like
go let's go to LA become famous no okay
no she was like you got a scholarship
you know your sister got this I went to
relocate and also she didn't want us to
be like 16 and pregnant so she's like
let's like change Georgia's la won't do
that to you
did none of us have kids oh yeah you're
right yeah Jesus but yeah no one gets
pregnant until they're 40 here I know no
for real though like in Atlanta
I was losing so much money from like
giving everyone money for their baby
showers and I didn't have a [ __ ] car
I don't know license like nothing I was
going to baby showers when I was 14
years old
Oh mom something's wrong with Nicole we
gotta go see her in the hospital she's
like what's wrong and I didn't want to
tell her she just had a kid you know
it's like I can't pay Cass money to go
see these [ __ ] anymore like I'm done
but yeah so then I moved up here and I
did acting went to every acting school
outside of the drama school that I went
to and then I started doing stand-up
comedy improv sketch all that stuff and
now I have a podcast that's cool do all
this internet stuff so yeah I feel like
that part of the world is what the world
sees as LA but then LA sees as a
different world like the Studio City
Hollywood North Hollywood the valley all
that area because a lot of people that
are working in the industry are trying
to get in like move there yeah so that
whole area I feel like it's it's own
little la bubble yeah it is that people
are really weird it's like very never
you grew up in that world right yeah so
it's like what kind of grew up at the
Playboy Mansion which is really really
weird and it's even more weird to think
that it's not relevant now you know what
I mean it's like oh my god it was so
iconic yeah it was I was going up there
when I was really young and I saw a lot
of people go up and a lot of people go
down and a lot of you know what I mean
it was just like whoa but it gave me a
good perspective like always be kind to
people always treat everyone equally
like don't be a diva don't be a [ __ ]
don't be late that's true matter what
you look like it doesn't matter you know
what you have it matters to you or as a
person if you like you know continue to
show up and be a good person and like
put in the work people will love and
respect you and I think that's important
wait how did you get in there under
agent stuff it was born with a fake ID
in no sense of time yeah sister would
get in and you just go yeah and no one
could tell that you're like a baby in
there mm-hmm yeah I know I was like
really bad but like it let you play with
the animals there I did it was so funny
cuz Easter just came and I was like oh
my gosh and I met someone from Australia
I was like I want to go there so bad you
know my name is Sydney I want to go to
it would be so cool but I've never been
and I was like the closest thing I've
been to Australia is like I had a
kangaroo kick me in the tit and the play
[Laughter]
mean they're cute and I was like beating
in a bottle and stuff but like they're
not nice domesticated don't yeah don't
mess with a kangaroo their legs scrappy
they are in the crocodiles they don't
know put a clock ahead and I was like oh
my gosh and there's like rich [ __ ] had
this like you know that lit what is it
is it Wolverine claws it's like you know
right kind of tattoo what is it no it
was like a ring it was like the is like
brass knuckles no yeah that's Atlanta
that's like okay I know well gosh
Cartier it was like the cardioid cat or
something here's like a cat or something
it's [ __ ] crazy expensive and it was
a crocodile cat I don't know what the
[ __ ] it was Belles like whoa that's how
many like playmates are living there
actually no I mean at the time I don't
know it's really weird actually is the
whole culture lifestyle of those small
like comment the word I mean it smelled
like old ass to be honest
you mean like old old house like that
when you walk into like a museum and
[ __ ] yeah yeah I mean you ever watching
like your grandparents house me like I'm
you guys need to renovate some [ __ ] cuz
like it smells like the seventies yeah
yeah yeah yeah well I thought money
would wash that smell away no it doesn't
smell of death yes yes this smells like
somebody's gonna die soon but it was
just it's all very weird like you guys
never have to grow up in that or were
you always around like good real people
you're always around good I never grew
up in the playboy imaginary just like
people that are like always trying to
like one-up you try it like you know
there's always like an mo behind like
their personality like they're not
really trying to be your friend
Chauncy [ __ ] yeah it's like
yeah you never had to deal with that I
mean I you know in my own weird way was
like a conservative Church please yeah
but it's it was weird it was weird cuz
they were all trying to be like I love
Jesus more there yeah it's it's really
it's like a lot of hypocrisy there yeah
everyone's trying to one-up each other
Jesus style but it's like everyone's
kind
I don't know like bless your heart honey
bless your heart and you know that there
like to my dad is like out modest each
other and it's like come on it's like I
don't care how many Bible verses you can
say but you're still an [ __ ] yeah
yeah I hate that I hate people to use
Jesus like that um but yeah so that's a
bit of my style I just still the Jesus
Ian I actually do it but I'm at my
cursing Christian Christian Christian
the cursing dysfunctional Christian you
know of like that's not perfect and I
own it I think that's important to like
just lead with that basic Jesus Christ
man David this morning she woke me up
after saying Jesus Christ Isaac as he
was saying he got a headache eating
something he didn't like but anyway
a lot of headaches that's a thing he
doesn't like it yeah my 11 year old
Casey watch things like Jesus Christ in
this the whole morning while I was
getting ready it just kept hearing that
guy oh my god I love that dude man he's
so unique that's amazing so apparently
that dude he's like he's like an OG
popper from like the Bay Area or some
[ __ ] like that and like people knew of
him he was like big in the popping
community that he did some crazy [ __ ]
with the prison for like like 10 or 15
years of jail I love people that are
into God that have like crazy stories
like that you're like I was in prison I
was like oh cracked out on meth for
years and now I totally changed my life
around and like okay you go we would do
a retreat they would always be like
these reformed gangsters to us and I'm
like none of us are in games at the
point of this none of you are and you
were never in a game do people know
crazy and we're all like nice kids
that's a funny is when they assume
you're an at-risk youth we regular but
to the adults they think that like
you're terribly wrong or something and
they need to bring this ex-con to come
and straighten you out
he's like how scary he's like
threatening get this guy out of your
broke oh my gosh that reminds me Chris
Farley playing the motivational speaker
in SNL you know a David Spade and he's
like I live in a van down by the river
how although all of them were they had
like some kind of create their testimony
I mean I try to scare the living [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of you when we don't even need
it do it like I have both my parents
they're right here good with you bro
Jesus Christ I'm never gonna I'm like
literally gonna be doing that for the
rest of the didn't Jesus crap you got to
watch that video no that was the best
thing is the own Instagram I wanna fall
yeah he like on YouTube he's all up and
right now do he has a better video now
where there shadowboxing Satan what
Saint comes up to you you gotta fight
him up and it's homies in the back just
this is the first round don't do I'm
gonna be sending that to like all the
guys that I don't need to be talking to
are you so you are you married who are
you married to you married to one no
she's mad to another agent booth I just
got divorced so it like super happiness
heart like how did you know when to well
he was cheating on me with a whole bunch
of prostitutes oh yeah that's a pretty
good yeah he paid for sex yeah yeah I
know it's weird right like you marry
someone cuz you're like I want it for
free forever so yeah how'd you find that
[ __ ] off my [ __ ] turned into the Grinch
and then I ultimately got cervical
cancer and then yeah after I file from
divorce yeah I was like such a try like
I'm gonna talk about that on my podcast
actually Girl Interrupted go check it
out please subscribe
that's a cliffhanger yeah it's pretty
great no I have like a crazy story but
I'm very positive person and I got
through it thank God literally thank God
and my mom and like you know you're
considered a cancer survivor I am am a
cancer survivor
yeah but well I mean I don't want to
like knock on wood I have to go to my
oncologist next month and like I had my
follow-up it was good I had surgery I
didn't have to do chemo or radiation was
like thank God but then it came back so
I was like it's so weird yeah so you had
no idea he had a hooker problem I had no
idea I was love bomb so I married a
narcissistic sociopath and I had no idea
what that was at the time so what they
do is they mirror you
and when they love bomb me like they
love everything you love they just want
to like they find out every day so you
thought you had everything in common
with this guy yeah and then the
triangulation started to happen where he
would like you know if every time he had
something good going on in my career he
would try to do something to you know
make it go sideways like you know cuz he
had to be number one yeah it was really
[ __ ] up but you know I got out of it a
lot of women don't get out of it like
that's like a really important lesson if
you're not happy you can leave you
always have an option
so it was one of the hardest things I've
ever done and I'm so glad I did it
few years my divorce took three and I
represented myself for a little bit in
California okay I can do a lot of things
but I'm not a good at attorney okay like
I am NOT good like I just got in from
the judge I'm like Your Honor I can't
believe I [ __ ] him either I was like
whoop Z but I got I didn't get alimony I
didn't get my attorneys fees because I
didn't have three attorneys yeah so
stupid cuz I didn't know any like
literally I didn't go into that marriage
going oh I want to get a divorce who
does what knows how to get a divorce
until you have to get one I know but
here's the kicker you know I was only 23
when I got married and he was only 57 oh
[ __ ] he was 57
holy mackerel I think [ __ ] daddy as
you move you know that doesn't show you
I really am committed to my daddy issues
I don't know what dude I like skips milf
and I went straight to go you know
Dyl yeah horrible I know so I wasn't
really into being a grandma anyway I was
like we're done you know podcast
wait what Girl Interrupted yeah yeah the
first episode now I got a listen to this
ya know it is crazy the first episode is
with my therapist who was our couples
therapist - oh yeah you were talking
about everything with her out on air
just I was yeah I was and I didn't it
was really interesting it was my first
episode so it's a little nervous to like
get it and all those stuff cause it's
been like three years
but isn't this stuff therapeutic though
it is therapeutic you know I think it's
like once I actually rerecord all this
stuff so like oh my god how deep you
guys want to go on this you guys at you
know you don't really go that deep
you're more like kind of fun and like
light so speaking I like reformed
gangsters and [ __ ] I was with the Bloods
and the Crips when I got 5150 which was
not my look when I was going through the
divorce and I talk about that and she's
the one who did it she like called the
cops and I asked because I'm a lot of
drugs like don't just don't do it
don't do a lot of drugs I'm like drink
you know when you're going through like
a traumatic situation just kind of
self-destructive it's not a good luck
you know you don't really make the best
moves so that's like my biggest advice
who's the one in your corner and you're
like that says like hey what the [ __ ] my
mom my mom is like my biggest supporter
but like what about your friends was
your mom younger than to do oh yeah yeah
[ __ ] up it was so funny like looking
back at it looks like the worst day of
my life I think looked at my dad and I
was like you realize this is your fault
right and he's like yeah I get it I was
like perfect well good I got married
really fast so instead of getting a
tattoo or getting a dog I got married
yeah because my grandfather just passed
away three weeks you know before I met
my husband we got married within four
months of knowing each other oh and then
my stepfather killed himself within
those three weeks I've really [ __ ] up
that story so my grandfather died August
21st three weeks later my stepfather
killed himself which was like all the
men in your life yeah yes and then like
I was like who the [ __ ] is gonna walk me
down the aisle I guess my dad
my mom got wasted at my wedding she
probably didn't want to see him no no it
was like my mom had I had to walk her
down the aisle I was like mom get your
[ __ ] together she locked herself in a
bathroom at the Beverly Hills Hotel it
was a nice place no it wasn't like at
the like ballroom it was like in a
[ __ ] yeah no it was it wasn't
anywhere nice and fancy where you ran
out the place it was like literally a
hotel room like it was like one of those
bungalows you know I was like I'm
getting married in a hotel room you know
I was like what I mean it's not a nice
hotel that's the Beverly Hills Hotel but
I was just like this is not what I
envisioned so you got like the butler's
cage yeah it was a bungalow so you can
get like little you know like you have
the bigger rooms or whatever and then
you have a little like there was a
little pool or whatever but it wasn't
like the ballroom where it's a million
dollar wedding you know what I mean it
wasn't anything like that but yeah but
that's why I got married so fast because
I was dealing with trauma
mm-hmm so that's like a lady
yeah so instead of like you know going
to therapy working myself I was like you
know I just want to be with someone that
loves me so don't do that either don't
rush into a relationship get to know the
person take it slow no you were 23 yeah
my brain wasn't fully formed and also
just don't get married before here 225
please if I can give any advice wait did
you guys get married before 20 if you
know the person really well is right now
I'm like but like four months like it's
good
[Music]